hello hello welcome to simulation I'm
your host down sake on and today we have
mayoral candidate Angela Lee odo hi Alan
thank you very much for having me thank
you thank you thank you yes I love your
red coat thank you
it so you will ladies new year yes yes
you like you like standing out and you
like being lastly I wear a lot of black
too but I am loud I am loud I love that
about you
I'm because you want to get [ __ ] done
that's right and you want to you want to
do it with passion you want to do want
to clean out a lot of the dunk we're
gonna get we're gonna get to this okay
and we're really grateful because it's
super important to be involved in
politics this has been something that we
don't we haven't been talking about too
much on simulation but we talk a lot
about globalization we talk a lot about
the different political struggles across
United States China all these places but
what about your local cities whether
you're in Minneapolis or San Diego or
wherever you live join some sort of
political Drive within your community
and understand better what's going on
what are the issues at hand and really
get involved at a deeper level learn thy
neighbor all this kind of stuff so I
have lived here six years now and I
haven't actually dive deep into San
Francisco politics yet and I'm really
happy that you and Mike and John Paul
have really brought me back into great
caring about going on important very
very important your backgrounds
fascinating why don't you give us a
little bit of an understanding about
what makes you such an awesome candidate
well especially your background let's go
to the background my background all
right born and raised in San Francisco
my father was the mayor of San Francisco
doing some incredibly tumultuous times
so it was quite an experience just being
around during those times more or less
being the daughter of the mayor started
with the Summer of Love then we had
zebra zodiac candy bombers SLA sink you
communicate stinkweed in seven it was
eight years of serious terrorism when
dad was mayor and yet he handled it like
no other mayor in the name
I mean looking back at my father's
administration he was incredible mayor
of San Francisco incredible and so being
his daughter and his only daughter with
five brothers I went everywhere with him
because my mother hated politics I mean
once the house the front door the house
got blown up that was enough so she
hated it so I became kind of like the
mini first lady and when everywhere with
my dad and is an amazing liberal
education yes amazing so then I went
into I went to my actually had four
children by the time I was 25 and then
my Italian husband did not want me to go
to law school so I waited until my baby
jump Paolo who you know was in nursery
school because it's important you know
to be be there as much as you can the
first few years and then I went back to
law school when I was 29 became a lawyer
couldn't pass the bar the first time so
I decided to run for office I finally
passed the bar the same year I won the
election in 1988 and I became president
of the Board of Supervisors with the
largest vote ever gotten in 1992 so for
those eight years I was honored and
privileged to have written some amazing
legislation that was because of the
amazing staff I had we did everything we
banned cigarettes for the first time in
the world
cigarette smoking in the workplace
because due to the effects of
second-hand smoking we allowed
alternative Chinese medicine acupuncture
and chiropractic to be covered in health
care benefits for city employees that
was a big issue at the time we
recognized chronic fatigue syndrome and
other immune system problems as being
part and parcel of depression which was
a big issue also at the time so I mean
we did some really cutting-edge
legislation and then we did some fun
legislation I did the film Commission
and I did the Youth Commission
I did the children's budget that the
bifurcates of the funds of the general
fund that goes specifically to children
after school activities and I had to go
to the ballot to do that because my
colleagues didn't agree and today
there's after-school programs or because
of that bifurcated budget so we did some
really fun things we did a lot of
environmental things a lot of climate
change issues at the very edge early
early stages do you know do you know who
David Brower is David Brower was at the
time the father of the environment and
then we did Earth Day with John
McConnell we started the beginnings of
and it all started in San Francisco and
whatever San Francisco did it would go
statewide national so it was really fun
especially like watching the progress of
the smoking ban I mean just two years
ago the president of Ireland called me
and thanked me because Ireland went
smoke free and so I mean has long
lasting effects that has saved thousands
and thousands of lives so we really had
a wonderful eight years in City Hall and
then I got term limited out which means
that I couldn't run for another term
so the audition was again President of
the Board of Supervisors right which is
right now with right now right right but
in my day it was a citywide vote and now
only on the floor now right now it's
District so in other words you can be
the president of the board and only have
gotten 6,000 votes in my day you had to
get 200,000 votes too and I you know
that's a whole different big discussion
but I believe that the city should have
at least six of the supervisors be
citywide for example I could never
represent just where I live they didn't
do it to the detriment of the other
districts I couldn't do it yeah and
depending upon how much you advocate and
how forceful you are you're going to
benefit your district much more then say
you know the other say Hunters Point or
sunset of the Richmond because you're
gonna get more money more funding for
your district I could never do that it's
one city to me yeah I could never
benefit one part of my city
to the detriment of another part of the
city so that's why it's different with
the Board of Supervisors today 92 to
2000 was your supervisor the Board of
Directors and all of these things that
you accomplished know I was elected
November 1988 I started in 89 in 197 89
to 90 cents yes cool and then before
that you had all this amazing
preparation from your father
I did you had a really good foundation
which so wired you properly for being
able to handle all these different
interdisciplinary ways the city works
and understanding how to benefit the
economy but also how to benefit with all
different types of policy that occurs
from kids health care medicine all yeah
right I think those years of my dad
being mayor we're an education education
that it wasn't aware of until I got back
into politics I think that's very true
yeah and then now 97 on I opened my
little law firm I didn't know what kind
of law I was going to practice my father
was a very famous antitrust lawyer for
my five brothers or lawyers and
antitrust lawyers with my father but
antitrust is it's a fascinating law but
it just takes too long I'm a pretty I
like to get things done you know it's I
think that's pretty apparent yeah yeah I
like to close the circle as quickly as I
possibly can but an african-american kid
came into my office and said that Wonder
Bread was discriminating against him and
so I investigated all of his allegations
and I decided that because I wrote the
minority business laws when I was
president of the Board of Supervisors
and the women business laws the MBE LBW
bees I wrote all of those into
legislation so that the minority and
women could participate in the
contracting of the City and County of
San Francisco since I done all that I
was really pretty well up on
discrimination law and so I took his
case
and it turned out I ended up
representing 23 african-americans that
got whittled down to 20 20 African
Americans against IBC Wonderbread and
it's the largest verdict in the history
of the nation it's the largest civil
rights verdict in the history of the
nation what was the one hundred and
thirty-five million dollars the judge
took it away the next day took away one
hundred and twelve million the next day
of it but it was the largest verdict
from a jury in the history of our civil
rights um Wow in the nation yeah pretty
cool
you discriminatory because there was no
brown Wonderbread or there was no
discrimination because they're African
Americans they were treated differently
because it's so oh and like where they
work with the Wonder Bread corporation
right right oh and they oh that's not Oh
as a matter of fact my clients I mean to
the degree where they would have to go
out into the next door to go to the
bathroom and they weren't allowed yeah
yeah it was really ugly and one of my
guys had worked there for forty years
and had never been promoted but he
taught everybody who was in management
he taught all the white guys in
management they jumped over him and went
to management and he's still getting
paid ten dollars an hour for 40 years
and we proved all of that to the degree
that was the largest verdict in history
why did he get reversed 112 million
dollars okay so there is a Supreme Court
case that says you cannot in punitive
damages which is damages to punish and
deter it's to make you mister
corporation stop doing this and punish
you for having done it okay so it's
called punitive damages you can only get
punitive damages against corporations
you can't get it against government
entities Wonderbread the government no
it is that's why I was able to get it
yeah yeah and then what about the 112
being rescinded what No so there's a
there is a Supreme Court case that says
you can't get more than
times what you make in punitive damages
so I mean Ellen it's I mean I could go
on and on but it's extremely
discriminatory because let's say you
make $27,000 a year and Lyanna over
there makes three million dollars a year
so Leanna can get 9 times 3 million last
can only get 9 times 27 thousands that
makes no sir the damages can be way more
egregious less money so somebody has to
beat that Supreme Court case someday
let's fill legislation so it's still
it's still the Supreme Court decision
well we'll work on that over yeah we'll
have to work on that yeah when I'm mayor
our yeah yeah it's ridiculous in my
opinion and what year was the case that
you just described in San Fran 2001 2001
and then what has happened over those
last like 15 years that is well I've
specialized the homeless are remember
that that's very interesting
yeah I specialize in group
discrimination I usually represent
anywhere from 8 to 20 plaintiffs I've
got several cases my law firm right now
where my daughter Angela Mia my son Joe
my son John Paolo work Johanna Angela
Meera lawyers Jim Paul Erdos are our
mediations and my other son Adolfo is a
master chef so they have the restaurants
Avington yeah yeah yeah yeah and I I
have four incredible children you know
three incredible daughters two daughter
long one son-in-law and maybe jump hallo
well you know we'll have another
incredible daughter-in-law yeah good
girlfriend yes she's wonderful
Deana so and then I have five incredible
grandchildren I mean absolutely
incredible so I did my law firm and then
I decided okay I won the Wonder Bread
case I'm gonna run for mayor again that
was the second time in 2003 well that's
a long story and that's a really brutal
story that campaign brutal but I just
missed it by about 1% and Gavin Newsom
needed me in the runoff desperately or
he would not have won so bottom line
after a lot of red roses from
Gavin and the other person running for
office Matt Gonzalez they kept bringing
me red roses to get my endorsement and I
told Matt Gonzalez he bought yellow
roses once I said no they gotta be red
you know let's get the roses great okay
so so I endorsed Gavin and on the ground
based on the promise that I would be
able to do something about homelessness
because it's so unfriendly and a member
st. Francis's order like I was telling
you earlier about Dante Alighieri it's
so very very important to me to take
care of the sick in the poor it's always
been a big part of who I am so I took
that job on we created the ten year plan
to end chronic homelessness and we
housed over 11,000 people extremely
successful plan yeah so I've done it yes
in this new in the mayor's race now I
know what you have to do to take care of
homelessness especially chronic which
means people living in tents but let's
unpack that as kind of the first
starting point of your campaign because
you had 11,000 people successfully over
eight over eight ten year ten year plan
and let's unpack that because a lot of
people like to know how it worked
there's sustainable permanent supportive
housing right and then there's clinics
on the bottom for them to be able to
interact and sort of work their way back
into a job and all this good stuff that
makes so much sense yes it really does
it really really does but trying to get
people to they understand it the way you
clearly have and be it's a big job your
heart and soul has to be into doing that
to do it yeah you can't just become
mayor of the city and then start being a
mayor and not pay attention to the
specifics of how you get Joe off the
street or Henry off the street to get
Henry off the street if he's lived on
the street four to six years meaning
he's chronic and he's triple diagnosed
mm-hm
okay he's the hardest to get off the
street yeah the easiest to get off the
street which is the new epidemic are are
the unaccompanied women who have a high
high percentage 70 to 80% have been
sexually abused as children
and new people on the streets right
those are easier to also guide them all
well they're generally new on the
streets yeah unaccompanied women are
generally new on the in the sense of a
year or so if you can get someone off
the street that's just been like evicted
they're the easiest to get off the
street if you can get someone off the
street before 90 days they're the
easiest to help get off the street and
and to help them and to get them into a
job situation first of all there are so
many governmental rights that a person
has they don't know about everybody says
everybody comes to San Francisco to get
all these wonderful benefits homeless
people especially the vet the veterans
and the the mentally ill and vets you
know the post-traumatic stress is a huge
issue and the mentally ill they don't
sit down and go oh I guess I can go over
to SSI and get the police great benefits
they don't think that way it is absurd
to say that people come to San Francisco
to get benefits because that's not why
they're in San Francisco there's if some
overwhelming a percentage of the
present-day homeless population lived in
San Francisco this is this could be a
potentially a small problem with
immigration though right in terms of the
benefits that people are getting from
the state small problem with immigration
with it with some immigrants coming to
reap the benefits of the system
especially when they're undocumented
anybody yeah but generally speaking
they're paid those are not homeless
people yeah yeah I was all just I would
say there is absolutely yeah but they're
generally speaking they have jobs and
they're paid by employers yeah yeah
versus not having it yeah SSI yeah or
any of the governmental supplements so
they need to actually be able to access
people on street scene be able to access
their benefits and get guidance and get
sustainable you would be surprised how
many people in the 10-year plan from
2004 to 2012 how many people started out
in 2005 or 6 getting those government
supplements and then moving into a job
once they got their unit I mean that's
amazing what percent of the people
rehoused
because we also sent a lot of people
back home that want to go home in the
homeward bound program part of the
10-year plan oh yeah
so the ones we actually housed
ninety-four percent are still in the
same unit they've been in since we
housed them Wow
yeah they're not back on the street
that's over ten thousand of them it's
pretty well know we homeward bound had
four thousand had four thousand rats
about six thousand
Wow whoa so okay so now that was with
Gavin like homeless sorry that was 2004
beginning we started in 2004 the plan
came out June 29th of 2004 and Gavin
became went to be lieutenant governor in
2011 and Edie took over in 2011-12 and
the housing we had in the pipeline for
permanent supportive housing with a
minute clinic on the bottom floor that
housing that was working so well in the
program got taken out of we had 17
buildings ten of them got taken out and
given to affordable housing no longer
four formerly homeless people so as a
consequence when we take people up the
staff would have anywhere to put them
yeah to take them and they would go
through programs whether it was alcohol
rehab or mental health or programs that
were very successful and then they'd be
put back on the street if a program is a
revolving door and put you back on the
same place you came from the program
needs to be stopped it needs to be
stopped
yeah that programs not rehabilitation no
it isn't and it's very harmful and it's
throwing millions and millions of
dollars away when we could be actually
housing people or sending them back to
their homes oh my gosh the budget for
this is 350 million dollars its boggling
and they want more it's boggling and you
don't need more where is all the yeah
the waste is crazy the race
the waste is crazy what well I thought I
was like something like $30,000 per
homeless person
87,000 yeah yeah they could be at the
Fairmont Hotel or at least it's the
Holiday Inn with breakfast in bed for
the amount of money we pay where is the
waste going now where is the lack of
common sense I mean what is the lack of
common sense in so many areas in this
mayor's race
fundamental lack of common sense okay
that this just rampant at City Hall
it really is people just don't do what
you just it doesn't take a genius to
realize that police officers need Tasers
okay Tasers with an education who are
better than a gun yeah I mean no I'm the
only candidate that's for Tasers with
education that supports the Police
Officers Association you would be
surprised the argument you hear against
Tasers
it makes absolutely no sense that
someone thinks it's better to have a gun
yeah then a Taser that's the number one
the other thing I think likes total
common sense is the San Francisco Police
Department is not allowed to interact
with Homeland Security on terrorism
Homeland Security is not allowed to
interact with the San Francisco Police
Department so so there's a terror 39
issue that exact what happened what do
you know that the police captain the
police chief never knew about it because
of these and its laws security probably
doesn't know San Francisco as well as
the same Frisco Police Department does
so they should work together why is
there a law that doesn't let them work
together it's really a common sense Gary
yeah
there's so much and I don't want to use
the word paranoia so I won't but there's
so much fear of authority see I grew up
in incumbency they want to stay and they
don't wonder wonder saying they don't
want to rock the boat but you got you
have to rock the boat to have a safe
city yeah we are an absolute national
target I don't think there's any
question about that from the pyramid too
you name it we are a target for
terrorism Golden Gate Bridge
the gay community the the the all of us
I mean there are many different reasons
why San Francisco is a target for us not
to have daily communications with only
our security is just simply crazy yeah
yeah so I mean so much of this is going
on in the mere sight I learned another
one just recently in the mayor's race
the Board of Supervisors did a law they
said the police officers cannot arrest
someone who burgers your car unless the
car was locked
hmm did you get that so I don't get that
yes like okay we're gonna get it doesn't
matter if the car was locked or not
burglary a nice little out and that is
that you have to prove the car was
locked I mean crazy legislation you
actually mentioned this to me you said
that it's ridiculous that there's not
funding for specific positions first of
all strip out funding from people that
are not doing job the job well and that
people have been in there for for almost
a decade not doing a rule here's the
head of DPW he's a nice man he's tired
he needs to find that he needs to retire
now and then hi you need new MTA that's
there well with enthusiasm that loved
the city yes keep the streets clean and
stop all the tearing up of all the
streets yeah yeah it's crazy in the new
also brought to light other things like
hiring police officers that live in the
city so that it's an earthquake city if
something happens there's not going to
be just 200 officers here because the
other 1500 are in the East Bay so
there's all these things that you've
brought to light that are very
interesting well we have to give them
housing too and teachers you mentioned
as well and please paramedics and
emergency services generally like
firefighters we have to be able to give
them affordable housing affordable
housing in San Francisco isn't
affordable to anyone making under a
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
year well yeah I there's there's there's
many situations that you could buy
maybe a room in a house that you could
live in for $1,500 a month instead of a
one-bedroom by yourself and that's not a
place for a family justice never been
that way San Francisco has always been
family friendly always built on family
you said that the percentage of under
was at 13 or 18 year olds went down from
like 25 to like under 12 or 12 percent
think that there's only 14 percent
families in San Francisco Wow and yeah
they just and pardon a lot of the
reasons why they migrate out are the
safety issues the homeless issue it's
school safety homeless I mean safety has
gotten out of control
the needle in the middle of the day yeah
yep it's out of control they need all
the sandbox in the case and the needle
in the sandbox that was talking at Wow
well that example I always use because
I'm the only parent in this mayor's race
and I think that that is a very you know
when we talk about experience having had
experience with children listen it's
very very important because like when
this little boy found the syringe at the
park and the sandbox
then went around and gave his friends a
shot in the arm with a dirty syringe
okay so it's like a parent's ultimate
nightmare okay one of my colleagues
whose name I won't mention one of my
opponents in this race asked me why
would he do that and I said because
that's what kids do what do you mean why
would he do that that's kids do you know
I mean it looked like a toy yeah and you
serious stuff and you're cleaning the
syringes off the streets yeah yourself
with the team that was amazing that was
amazing you're actually doing it yeah
that's the thing you got actually do it
you can't just talk about it right and
you've done it so it was such an
education to Alan to do it with such all
the godless syringes we found all of the
from syringes to feces to drugs
themselves to the things that we found
in just a 6 square block area was
shocking yeah shocking
yeah it's time and by the way that
morning would we do the clean streets
we're gonna be doing them every two
weeks but we started two weeks ago that
day we I have three people that were
sleeping on the street one was in the
park and two was it - a couple was in
the doorway and they're both in the unit
right now all three of them are in a
unit well the the single man is in a
rehab and then a unit in one morning
warning you so when I win the mayor's
race I'm going to spend the first few
months out of the street housing people
but let's talk about this because I
think this is something that is very
close to me and a lot of people that are
my age is I keep thinking about how
there are so many less units residency's
for people that really need the help
right now so we talk a lot about the
sustainable permanent supportive housing
and without any actual units or
residences or funding towards those
things it's really difficult to
accomplish that one thing that's again
very close to me is the technology
sector right and something that I feel
is a very common thread within the San
Francisco is I frequently talk to people
that work in the tech industry and I ask
them have you been in the Pacific Ocean
yet and and and they tell me no I've
lived here two years and I haven't been
there yet I asked them I asked them
about or have you gotten involved in
politics whatsoever DS you know that the
mayoral race is happening right now
again it's a big fat no and a lot of the
time and so let's hope they stay home
and don't vote well yeah let's I'm just
kidding you know just kidding buddy to
vote I want everyone to vote yeah just
kidding let's and let's get let's get
pass along this the education of them
and to other especially c-level
executives that have brought thousands
of employees to the city that are yes
contributing massively to the economy
but they're also bringing a lot of lyft
and uber drivers into the city for
70,000 additional cars every single day
come in to do that driving and then with
their massive multi
million-dollar profits why don't we pool
some of those profits in together from
these massive technology companies and
have them have be a sponsor for the
supportive housing it's something that
would really love to work with me and
I'd love your house on absolutely that's
the way it has to be done also the city
has several properties that we could
rehab and make some SROs you know the
single resident I've lived in those yeah
crazy those rehab them and make them for
formerly homeless so we do have a lot of
options but we do need to bring together
what we need to do is make sure we're
spending every dollar as much of every
dollar as possible on housing the person
and not on admin when I was president
the Board of Supervisors I did an audit
of the Housing Authority and I was so
stunned to learn that 75 cents of every
dollar went to admin 75 cents of every
dollar went to the administration out of
the whole but of the whole Housing
Authority budget whoa yeah it was just
totally would it was a joke
and these are the opposite if not even
more yeah right yeah right but you know
you're talking about the voter that
doesn't know what's going on out there
in politics I think there's a problem
with people understanding cause the
causal connection between being involved
and actually changing the viability of a
city in other words if you you need to
connect the fact that you think that
Street is dirty with who you elect
correct yep and your own actions every
single day and your own actions but it's
also that people that you elect either
doing the job or they're not yes and
your vote in San Francisco people win
mayor's races by a hundred and forty
votes okay I mean it's a very Club
people win with Board of Supervisors by
20 yeah well yeah that's really so
you've got to go vote I mean it's really
important that's one person will clean
the streets one person well okay then
that's your whole decision and that's
your that's why education about what's
going on and we are gonna help with this
we're gonna help with savings
the budget is 10 billion dollars that is
if that's more than the GDP of a lot of
countries of course a lot of states but
a lot of countries I had to one of the
opponents at the panel the other night
she was talking about adding more so I
was talking about adding more people to
the payroll and I heard a stopper I said
wait a minute before you're doing all
this adding of people in taxes hold on
do you have an understanding that 10
billion dollars 1 billion dollars is a
thousand million No 1 billion is a
thousand millions and you've got ten
billion dollars for one city it's crazy
waste and it's 7x7 sperm it's crazy
waste okay we don't need to add a lot of
new employees we need to make the
existing ploys do their job department
heads are key because they're running
their own feet domes yeah literally
because they've never they haven't had a
mayor in recent years that they thought
would fire them yeah and they were right
yep which is why they're not voting for
me because I want to put Humpty Dumpty
back together again in Reverse not it's
not going to be 75 percent of the budget
is going to yeah which is a different it
still happens with other budgets as well
we can also go to admin I don't know
what it is today and by no means am I
saying the Housing Authority is that bad
today but it was when I was a prisoner
DPW MTA they're getting erect
it's the DPW is responsible for keeping
the streets clean right and that's kind
of why the streets aren't clean right
right now and MTA is tearing up a lot of
the streets and they're taking oh this
was so interesting when you mention this
because my uncle and I talk about it all
the time that all of a sudden you'll see
that the company that was doing the
construction on the street now has oh we
have more budget we need to spend that
budget what are you doing what they just
did it's it's insane waste and they're
getting elect their gonna you know do it
is it's insane waste and the traffic
that's 70,000 additional cars Van Ness
is torn up right now you know
it's like come on China can build a
world-class Convention Center in Tianjin
in frickin nine in nine months and the
escalator at 24th and mission has been
out for the last right six months and
this is it's not cool it needs to be
fixed and especially with tech because a
lot of the people that you mentioned
that the average you said the average
salary to be able to sustainably live in
Sanford this goes over a hundred
thousand dollars a lot of those rules
our technology company rolls that there
greenie and thousands of hours they're
buying out these buildings you also have
responsibility to work with them to help
solve these issues and that that's
something that's really close to my
heart of wanting to solve and get these
twenty five year olds that are making
100k doing programming or designing and
stuff I really want them to get more
involved and we will do that we will
make San Francisco has the potential to
be a you of model city with arcology
focus on ecology and architecture
transit systems that are super good
however health care systems the housing
systems all this stuff and it's just
we're not we're not there yet but but we
have the ability to get there the Board
of Supervisors this city was beautiful
it was clean
we had the homeless situation somewhat
taken care of
you never saw tens of brand-new tents
happened after occupy SF remember occupy
ourselves okay so the homeless saw these
people that were occupying SF rebelling
against the government they saw them
buying tents to live in you know and
they thought oh that's an idea easy for
them to transit with it too and the
other hand you don't want people
sleeping in you know cold winters or
anything like that we need to give
people a place to sleep and try to get
them on their on their feet so that they
can have a productive life in the city
but when you're talking about that one
person that doesn't know the young kids
that do make that kind of money I think
I think the Internet age is incredibly
exciting as it is has also brought about
kind of a
the person the are just in to the
telephone and into the computer and not
necessarily noticing the dirty streets
then when they get married and have one
child and they realize that the streets
are filthy or when they start to go see
the Pacific Ocean and realize hey wait a
minute this street is really filthy but
it takes something like a tipping point
like Malcolm Gladwell's tipping point
yeah it takes something that makes them
realize wow this street is really dirty
to kind of get them out of their own
world of the internet because the
Internet is the IT young kids that are
all over San Francisco they really are
in their own world and that's great but
when they wake up from their own world
and realize that guys shooting himself
yeah up with a syringe that's very
dangerous yeah you know these are
serious the city has some of the worst
problems I think it's ever had and I'm
coming from an era where we had you know
terrorists homegrown terrorists like the
SLA and thank you and the rest of it
what let's educate about when all this
is happening so when can people can get
involved Alioto for mayor Italiano for
mayor calm our headquarters is at 700
Montgomery and we have a new
headquarters opening at 166 West Portal
cool west side of the city is extremely
important to me yeah and I want to make
them make sure that we answer all of the
questions that we need to answer that
are very very different questions from
the west side to the east side to the
north side and the south side very
different community issues very very
different and so it's very important to
me to make sure the Chinese community
for example is very very important
contingency in this particular mayor's
race and so we're reaching out as much
as we possibly can and doing I believe a
very good job there but the Irish
community when I I learned that they
really want the monument at one of the
piers how easy was that that yeah
explain that to your audience because
that was so easy
attending the Irish community when we
had the debate there
there the moderator is Irish and then
those who crowd is more than more than
half of the crowd is that the Irish
Cultural Center which my father opened
which was fun to see the photographs
that's right you mentioned that too
that's so that's so interesting because
this is such a multicultural City and
because that that is the reason why they
want the monument cuz Irish came and did
so much work to build out you can
explain it better than I can i recently
Italian the Chinese in them and of
course the Mexicans I mean everybody
worked together in those early years
yeah and really built the city they were
the builders a lot of the Italians were
the bankers a AP Giannini started Bank
of Italy and then became Bank of America
and that was after the 1906 earthquake
because none of the other banks would
give money to people without collateral
and nobody had collateral because the
building's yeah we're on the ground yeah
and so they didn't have valuable
collateral our any assets for that
matter and AP Giannini literally gave
out loans so we became the financial and
the legal center of the west of the
Mississippi and and now we're you know
the Internet Center the west of the
Mississippi but unbelievable wonderful
cultures yes unbelievable and the Irish
and the Italians you know there always
seem to have migrated the same time it's
very interesting to Boston and then to
the to the west coast so all mr.
Birmingham wanted all he's wanted from
the city government was this monument to
the potato famine which is you know
monumental in the eyes of the Irish and
monument only in the world view eyes
Kenneth Clark and and his series on
civilization talks about the devastation
of the the potato famine like what it
did to the world one and a half and we
built so much of the city police just
give us yes just give us a monument to
to Sela
to celebrate er to honor and respect the
people from the that
I'm that well that's why so many Irish
came to America was the potato famine
yeah so it's very symbolic tall yeah I
wish that our here
I love the multicultural aspect to the
city I just didn't like I just can't I
can't get over how cool it is to be able
to just drive into different parts of
the world basically or walk into them
and it just feels so cool to be able to
do that yeah see I think that that's
kind of the upset I felt when I decided
to run for mayor it's that some of the
people it's not a lot of them in City
Hall don't understand that and yet you
do and you're kind of new here
innocence you've been here six years
they they don't understand the
multicultural in this of San Francisco
and how it's important that every
culture be treated equally and that not
want to be put over the other or one be
ignored very important yeah and to
provide such simple things like just
being able to build them a monument to
represent something so important to the
culture that's helped the city so much
right and it seems like so easy that's
is really that should be the snap of a
finger that really said yeah Kevin where
do you want the money yeah the MC of the
evening was moaning his outcast state
with about
they just won't give this monument so I
just turn them and say Kevin where would
you like this monument in other words an
elected official can usually just say
where do you want it I'll do it
yes I mean I can't tell you how many
times people came into my city hall
office and and I look at them and go
that's really horrible let me fix that
right now you know the one that comes to
mind I had some that were really tragic
we were at the very beginning and the
myth the beginning of the AIDS epidemic
HIV and zero positive situation where
people were afraid to be in the room
with anyone HIV and I was not and so I
had a lot I did so much HIV legislation
we added so many medicines to the
federal aid app list that they wouldn't
let him have it
we went down to Mexico and got medicines
which was probably an illegal act of
thinking back on it but people were
dying in serious pain serious pain and
so they would come into my office and
they would say you know my lover is
dying or my partner is dying and they
won't let me in the emergency room I
fixed that in two weeks took me two
weeks to undo that shame that someone
that close couldn't be in the emergency
room because they weren't quote unquote
a husband or quote unquote a father a
mother or a brother
and at that time we literally had a
thousand young men a week I will never
forget the headline of the bar var
reported the Bay Area reporter one
thousand in one week died and we were in
the middle of this massive epidemic so
it wasn't like I'm gonna take my time
and get those medicines on this list
that's also when I legalized medicinal
marijuana
my husband died very very slowly and
very painfully from cancer stomach
cancer he was a chef like my son
Adolfo and at the towards the end of his
death on 1990 UCSF had given him a
little can of literally of joints that
were cut
very clean and he would smoke them and
he would be able to come downstairs to
dinner he would be able to communicate
with his friends he had hundreds of
friends and his four children and then
ucsf took it away and Here I am a
supervisor of the City and County of San
Francisco left in the position of having
to get marijuana yeah which was totally
illegal yeah so I legalized it yeah for
medicinal purposes first and experience
the first time in the first law ever
written to mid for medicinal marijuana
important stuff
people shouldn't die in that kind of
pain not to get emotional on you but you
know all these young men were dying yeah
it was just you know and then and then
Ryan white died and Ryan White funding I
was living in Washington DC getting the
federal funding for the AIDS epidemic
and we did really really well
the medicines that we got put onto the a
tap list the federal list at the time
eventually created the cocktail that of
course is saving lives
we did great work but we did it we
didn't talk about it yeah yep that's the
biggest differentiator that I felt
affirmed I can't get over your energy
and enthusiasm about that week is so
great to be able to help people yes so
great you know we had an eidetic I wrote
a book called straight to the heart
political cantos based on Dante's
Inferno which is Dante's hell okay and I
literally put all the politicians that
did nothing in a time of moral turpitude
to act I put them all in the layers of
health it was a best-seller at the time
and I have to get you one you would love
it and unfortunately a lot of the
politicians are still alive so they're
mad at me but having said that it was
such a time to act because of the
emergencies of what we were living
through and people
did they who did or I would take it to
the ballot yeah and win at the ballot
okay what the Board of Supervisors is
addressing today is bad but it's nothing
like that
your fire for getting things done is oh
it burns so bright it does is what what
else
maybe we touch on this I think this is
important to touch on the construction
of new properties and how and how we
should go about that it's it seems to be
that overall the idea of increasing
housing is really important but we're
placing them in certain places is also
really important near transit lines is
important but but it's also putting in a
certain percentage of the unit's to be
able to be afforded by teachers and
firefighters and paramedics all that
good stuff really important so like
what's your plan for that well when we
did the housing for the formerly
homeless some of the buildings that we
did had like 300 units in it and we
would do the first few floors would be
formerly homeless then there would be
below more below affordable housing and
then affordable housing in the market
rate at the top teared up was just
exactly mixed housing excuse and used to
work with developers to be able to do
that totally works
yeah totally works and there's been some
of it done but nowhere near enough and
of course the formerly housing have been
taken out completely it's very very rare
to find units because I see all these
new five seven story kind of condo
buildings going up and I don't know if
the developers it seems as though
they're probably sacrificing 50% of
their property it's right now it's 18 to
20 percent of the building is affordable
the issue is whether it would ever go
higher that's the big fight yeah that's
not even that bad for what what in what
is the percentage because I always think
about all shareholders are always trying
to figure out a way to maximize so what
is the 20 what out of that 20% that is
affordable housing how much lower is
that then let's say the $3,000 per one
bed
sort of you have to make $130,000 to
live even remotely comfortably and
affordable in what we're calling
affordable that's that's my point
affordable isn't affordable I mean
affordable isn't affordable especially
if you want to get married and have
children it's just not affordable
however you know you talk to developers
and I've talked to so many developers
and I understand their frustration
absolutely they can't get permits
they're told they go ahead and do it and
then 10 years later they've got a hole
in the ground then we haven't been
allowed to build the planning department
permit process has to be brought into a
one-stop shop so you get everything in
one place and get it done that's another
area where just get the job done or
don't
don't let them build in other words
don't tell them yes you can build here
and then hold them up ten years yeah you
know what I mean if you're gonna say yes
you can build here then give them the
permits to build yeah just assuming all
safety first right yeah but I have been
speaking to a lot of developers lately
and and they'll tell me even at eighteen
and twenty percent affordable in a
building that say has 125 apartment well
each of the twenty two percent
affordable is six hundred thousand
dollar loss over the span of to the
developer oh okay okay
yeah which is you know formidable so
somebody needs to either be able to
develop more efficiently yeah
or develop like we were talking about
with the intention of taking some of the
Google Facebook sales for selected money
and just being like hey let's put this
to a really really well made a
sustainable permanent housing for
homeless people for people that teachers
police officers paramedics this seems
like that's the absolute right way to go
for me because I just feel like they've
done such a good job at maximizing their
value to the world but also the amount
of money that they get from being you
know software driven and then they don't
even need to have a physical tangible
product you can just be digitally made
on your computers and things like that
so you know if they can
or to pay $150,000 salaries and have all
the amenities that they have they can
also afford to help the city that they
now all live in and Alan the point there
on top of exactly what you're saying is
they're very the IT billionaires in San
Francisco are extremely philanthropic
they give give give our hospitals yeah I
mean you know our hospitals and yeah
really essential Benioff and Zuckerberg
well what's really important and they
were extremely generous okay and that
was all saying they're not yeah here's
the problem the IT the government and
the community neighborhood people are
not in the same room okay if you put all
three of them in the same room then the
IT people would understand we need the
money to go towards this this and this
yeah in other words you really don't
understand what we needed to go yeah
yeah yeah like infrastructure of the
city streets well for example would how
would you brand bene offers Zuckerberg
on cleaning the streets that's another
interesting point is that Marc Benioff a
friend not right now I'm just I'm just
making a thought-provoking comment I'm
not saying I went to the table you I
just want to bring them to the table and
say look this is what we really need
okay yep not kind of what you all want
to pick and choose of what you want to
give to which is great that you're
giving but this is what we need for you
to give to yeah for example yep we you
know you bring 3,000 new employees to
town they don't have housing the
infrastructure of the streets is a
nightmare yeah and they're using the
streets right and we've got this uber
lyft chariot problem yeah well there are
70,000 new cars on the street and
there's no get back at all to the city
there's no business tax there's no
nothing
yeah no I'm not a big taxing person but
uber is a business lift as a business
chair it's a business they should be
taxed yes yes yes and and not have the
the tax offloaded on to the driver
salaries that seems to be a big issue
right now how much are they really being
paid I've heard very low dollars now
I've heard also up to 30 which is why
people come from Sacramento don't sleep
in their cars and that kind of stuff the
one that I had gentlemen I had the other
day was from Bakersfield that's like
eight hours away it's it's like
Bakersfield
so just to come make money so all right
look we do we'll wrap it up with a
couple of quick quick ease so when is
the election the election is June 5th
and the fascinating thing about this
election is that it's Instant Runoff in
other words there'll be no runoff if a
first person doesn't get 50% then they
then they count the second so you will
vote for three people for mayor and you
don't have to vote for three people you
know you vote for just one if you want
yes yes but they will go to number two
or number three if the person doesn't
get the percentage okay
and so June 5th and the work that you
can do is come to come to our
headquarters yeah we're at 700
Montgomery Aliano for mayor calm we're
also at 166 West Portal and we would
love to have you come down and help us
out we have dozens if not hundreds of
volunteers at the moment we're going to
be calling starting you know and in
April we're going to be calling all of
the voters and ask amendment that voted
yet because absentee is a big issue and
absentee ballots can be out there from
the first week of May until the Election
Day itself people need a ride to the
polls you know that's what they used to
do as a kid when I was 16 they used to
drive everyone to the polls to vote for
my dad and you don't see a lot of that
arguments old-time campaigning yeah I'm
doing billboards and bus stops and old
times you're painting I'm gonna get up
at 5 o'clock in the morning to go to
Glen Ellyn you know transit and hand out
my flyers and it's it's time campaigning
my opinion works yeah
as a consequence that's what our
campaign is doing so we need a lot of
volunteers we're gonna do door hangers
we're going to do everything that we can
do to get our message out to the voters
that we need to fix all of these bad
things that are happening to our great
city San Francisco is one of the most
beautiful cities in the world it is one
of the places everybody what they let
the heart yeah I mean the song says it
all today it isn't today you don't leave
your heart here yeah things are not good
right now and it's the first time in my
entire life I can say San Francisco's
not being a livable city and it's not
gorgeous like it's always been but it
easily could be you have to get the
determination to do it and angela has
that I have that and if you guys also
another good way is just to go to an
actual debate and go and see them such
as a and partly participate just go see
them speak and learn about it
so maybe just just a couple quick
questions for you you can be quick with
them so we can move on these are kind of
our fun simulation simulation questions
are so am I gonna read about these fun
simulation questions well they're fairly
fun and easy I think so you can give yes
or no what or explain as much as you
want but are we alone in the cosmos are
we alone in the cosmos I asked you
before when I heard that question kind
of weather is this a religious question
no I don't believe we're alone in the
cosmos you think there's other conscious
life somewhere around other stars I
think that it would be very egotistical
of us to believe that we're the only
galaxies yeah and then how about do you
think we're in a computer simulation do
you think we live in one I'm not sure I
know what that means it's like an
advanced civilization gets enough power
and processing to be able to harvest the
power of their star something to be able
to simulate the reality that we live in
all of ourselves all of our atoms all of
our I hope conscious thoughts you know
face reality what do you think not did
you see that story on 60 minutes
about the cloned pulley polo phony
ponies fascinating I need a little oh my
gosh you should see it's Sunday night
there's this guy in Argentina
his name's Adolfo has cloned his entire
polo team and their number-one winners
from one whole wall you have to watch as
it's 60 minutes a guy was incredible and
it's just amazing what he's done ya know
he's winning everything with an entire
team of clone horses so I was gonna say
Alfred Hitchcock er Twilight Zone but it
goes so far ba ya ya know about I had no
idea that kind of clothing was going on
um no idea taketake traits for humans
for intelligence for metabolism for all
these different things what kind of a
future will we live in at that point
these are the thoughts that we also like
having on here it's really important to
dedicate time to our city what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world
your smile is beautiful you know what I
mean I what is the most beautiful thing
in the world probably what is the most
beautiful probably a newborn baby or you
know I'm very religious so I've been a
member of Saint Francis's order since I
was 15 years old the third order of
secular order of Franciscans and Saint
Francis lived his whole life taking care
of the sick and the poor and he believed
that everything everything was the face
of Jesus Christ or the face of God the
Father
everything from the flower to the donkey
everything represented God and was
beautiful very very true you know he
lived an amazing life and eight hundred
years later after millions and millions
of people who have been sick and poor
we've been taken care of by his order
the Franciscan Order it's a joyful life
it's fascinating how joyful his life was
being married to lady poverty poverty to
st. Francis of Assisi was joy
so when I go into all of these tents and
I sit down and talk to the homeless
people I totally understand what
Francesca was talking about when he
would talk about the joy in the face of
poverty because the truth is is that
sometimes people don't really want to be
strapped down to a nine to six they kind
of want to be able to live freely in a
different way that we sometimes don't
understand so there's a whole different
conversation he had with every single
person and figure them out and figure
out how we can help it's really been
kind of funny there is one lady running
for mayor who often mentioned Saint
Francis and that and I don't I don't
correct people or anything but I am a
Franciscan I am a st. Francis himself
Street scholar I mean literally okay
he has been my best friend since I was
fifteen years old
literally so she's talking about well
st. Francis wouldn't let those people
live on the street and I'm thinking to
myself is she kidding st. Francis would
be the first to join the family on the
street he was not into making sure
someone had a house he was making sure
that someone understood the joy of God
yeah yeah you know so he would not be
housing homeless people he would be
taking care of them but he would not be
necessarily housing them he himself
lived in the desert lived on the
mountains lived was a hermit for six
months of the year when he wasn't out
trying to take care of the sick and the
poor so it's been really fascinating
having this one lady in the race named
Amy quotes st. Francis as someone who
would be housing the homeless you have
so much experience you have so much
energy of so much passion we definitely
recommend checking out Alioto for Mary
thank you thank you thank you so much
thanks Roger
really well sorry I couldn't get to the
cosmic question as I'm not sure about
Gideon we were in there crushing it on
everything else though yes
anything else in your side of the cosmos
I don't know we're gonna work we're
gonna work together and I really hope to
see some great beautiful change to the
city thank you so much thank you
everyone for tuning in if you had a good
time give us a like to subscribe a
comment please go and share the content
with other people get them inspired to
make political action economic change or
community change in their nearby
communities and